jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, starting.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I think…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So the…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So, the first thing… Was it regarding the training data?
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So, Liu, if you want to kind of elaborate on that?
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Hmm.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: It's basically, he… there was a list of things that he had. He was saying that he could start with, even without those, but it would be great if he could have the label, like, what input goes to what output, and what we have to do.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Do you want to add anything there?
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Mother .
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: health delivery, yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Can you give somebody every day.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, I think it was sent to everyone, so… Yep.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, so I thought that…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yes,
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: That's, the 6th of April.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: You can see a whole bunch of stuff.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Expressive.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Do you have it?
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Do you have… do you have the email?
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: If it was sent to you. We can forward it back to you.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: If anyone can't find it, we'll resend it.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: And providing the information you asked for. And I was looking… I think in the last meeting.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: It's this cool.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: It's the… I think what happened was, he was looking for a fresh email instead of the reply itself, so yeah, it did have it.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Awesome. Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: No.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: You remember, like, if you're just seeing… It was responding to your email.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I don't even know who's asking that before.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, indeed.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Here's my inbox, and it pulls emails.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Good idea. Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: For these? Yeah, I think you can just ask them, like… Yeah. Yeah. Or actually… Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: depending on whatever specific type of product they will target.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, so you can just sort… Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Like, you just use the Android. So it should work.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yes, I am. Are you not able to see.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So I guess the question would be is, how large is the data set?
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: It's… They wanted to focus on a specific product, and then, like, understand how that goes down there.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: But the data I send is basically for everything. So, I send them all sorts of cards, you know.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: One time to know.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: They can cooperate. Okay.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: You want them drinking on it. Come on.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, I think he's not able to access, that's the thing, but yeah, let's get through that.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Moved here.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: What was this one?
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I'm standing there.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Can we Actually, just use a CS.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: This…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh, this one.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I think that was the issue, though.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: through, like, the CS.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Okay, yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Other than that…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, there was one other thing. We're… Lou, he started work on it, and he's…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Let's tackle some more.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, but, he also mentioned that
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: The Claude, token limit is, running out pretty fast. I think he ran out within 20 minutes or something, so… Okay.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So, so there is… I believe one of you guys taking your token a little bit, and none of your…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah. So, I'll probably implement, like, Usage policy?
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: But keep the limits the same. Yeah, yeah. So, I mean, if you guys do more than that, then I would say…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, I don't think, because that portion is the one that's really heavy right now. Everyone else is more regarding making documents and stuff, so you're not… I don't think we're gonna hit that really soon.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, don't even pop up.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, Dr. Douglas.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I hope you came by again.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: And you can also, equipped.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I had people.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Cool.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: they removed the whole promoting. Oh. So now you just have, like…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: May you be billed for every single week.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I did not know that,
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So, is the… still, like, the whole group policy possible for, like, all families?
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: member-level policy right now, so let me see if I can… Okay. So it's a pay-as-you-go policy with scrum.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: We initially had this usage for anything, which they completely worked out.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I guess I've been facing a lot of outages with Florida, so I think the demand might be too much on there.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Like, if you're using that, I would just say use it anytime which is not at 95.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Alright, so…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I'm already recording it.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Oh.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, there's a trick people are finding where if you start the conversation before 9,
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Then it, like, it won't take the people, like, it'll be grouped as, like, a message that's started outside, even though you're using it during 95.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Two weeks ago or something, one week ago.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: But that… that just makes sure you get a session moving, though. Because now you can't even start a session for that, because…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: There's so many people using technology.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: And these are your handles everyone.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Music that one.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah. Credit, I just got the email for codex, yeah. I'm making the account right now. I already have way too many accounts for all this AI stuff, but I'm making a new one.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: they sent it both to my previous university at UMass, and
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: This one as well, so I'm making two accounts right now.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: They've not… they've not, like, closed down my previous one, so I might as well.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, those were the two things that I think, when I was talking with Lou, that, you know, when he was making it, that he raised them. And, I was also unsure about, like.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: how the group thing would work as well. Other than that.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: We're pretty much working on the ML portion right now. Leo, he has made some progress, and… but the training still has to be done. I don't think the training's done right.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Yeah, excellent. So… We have the previous one and this one, so that's… that's about that.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I would also suggest that you guys should pick them up.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: understand how to just use AI tools again? Yeah. Because…
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I think there's a lot of,
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: It's a lot to learn, really, just a lot to understand.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: It goes on.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: For example, just when it comes to, like, token usage or context management, there's just so much for it.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Let's see.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Let me give you more details about our contact line.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: So the thing is, if you're using an only chat, which only has too much in it, and you're trying to
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: I'll go forward in the chat.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: We don't need to principles need to be worked on.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: And that's just not the beat.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: Every single time, we technically open up a new section.
jaivards@andrew.cmu.edu: It was great.
Ashritha: I'm a bit confused.
Ashritha: Take care.
Ashritha: I think there's an echo.
Ashritha: I should talk.
Ashritha: This should be fine. Yeah, this is… sorry about that.
Ashritha: So, when you're talking about the context serves, right, so…
Ashritha: If you have already had a previous conversation.
Ashritha: Doesn't it just compact it, though? It can still keep working there. No, it does compact it, but the thing is, for example, if you're asking me to completely understand the question.
Ashritha: Or a question which is very, like, slightly related to your current conversation.
Ashritha: it'll still compact all of the composition that happened before, so instead of just using the 20 words that you sent right now, it'll use the 20 plus 400, 500 words that you used before. Got it, so it still tries to relate to that email. So that would be, like, a bigger token that's been sent.
Ashritha: I've also been facing a few issues, but I'm just not, I guess, on the arena.
Ashritha: how the… how it's, like, using the previous context, so… It's not totally transparent, but you… there's, like, a few ways, or just practices which you can use to just not let that happen. And those practices might just help you guys a little bit.
Ashritha: to just not hit the victory. I'll definitely make that one.
Ashritha: Right now, just two.
Ashritha: I'd like to have a common set of best practices that people use. You can just… honestly, you can just go on YouTube, or even Claude has free courses, which they give out. Those courses are, like, how much? And how long?
Ashritha: I think we did a couple of those… We did do good, yeah.
Ashritha: The studio has two courses that, we were, basically part of the work that we do, and I think you get a cancer.
Ashritha: So, yeah, I've not gone through all that, but, probably should. There's so much that's changed, it's so kind of… there's too much change, there's too much to keep up, and that's kind of a problem, too. Yeah, it's… Lord released us 4.7, right? Like, half an hour, 30 minutes ago,
Ashritha: chargy, like, oh god, it's really something.
Ashritha: definitely backed up all my data analysis, and I heard about that.
Ashritha: cybersecurity news about the finding bugs and 37 rules. Oh, no, we've met those.
Ashritha: Yeah, I didn't even think that OpenVSD was even possible, to, like, do anything, much less crash it from internet.
Ashritha: It's also, like, automatic. Yeah, don't dig too much into that. Yeah.
Ashritha: We do have, updated SOW, so, Cliff has just given some more feedback on that as well, so…
Ashritha: We, I will, like, correct the… correct that and show, like, an updated version. So, should we have digital signature on it, or should I print it out and show it, like, for signatures? I'm not sure.
Ashritha: Well, ideally, yeah, you want to go through the process of doing the SOW and getting the client to provide their input on it. You know, you can do electronic signing, you can do physical signing. The whole idea is just to make sure that you have some sort of thing, people acknowledging that this current version is what you guys are sending it to.
Ashritha: I'll… I'll still have to update it with his, feedback, so I'll… but I will be sending it to you anyway as well.
Ashritha: Yeah, I'll go through it again. I went through the last one, I had a few moments, but I just noticed that.
Ashritha: No, no, it's, it's, I should have, like, there, there's, the… it was not as up to the… there, there was a template that I could have used that, that, that's much more in line with what CME uses, so it did forward, like, a lot of examples, so I re-remarked using that.
Ashritha: I think it's a lot better then.
Ashritha: Yeah. The examples are good. I mean, the whole point here is the exercise of doing it. It's not a legal document, but it's a good exercise for the team you do. Yeah, it's good to come to a consensus. Yeah.
Ashritha: Other than that… -Oh.
Ashritha: we actually…
Ashritha: we're still, I guess, starting off into the, some of the coding, I guess, and some TAML part.
Ashritha: So, we actually don't have a lot to show right now. It's still… And, yeah, I was a bit hesitant, I considered…
Ashritha: maybe, like, you know, that the meeting might be short, but we actually are kind of in the weeds right now, so it would take a bit before we can show, like, some of the things that we've actually finished. I mean, technically, at least I wasn't expecting anything until, like, summer started, so that's, that's okay.
Ashritha: I think right now, we've been working a bit on the architecture side of things, and, we had a few…
Ashritha: ideas on how we're going to architect the entire thing. Right now, we had a… I think we've not finalized, but we have a basic structure in mind. I think we will be discussing that with our architecture coach. We had one discussion before, I said, and he had a few review points, and we're gonna go back to him. I think by the end of this month, we'll have a…
Ashritha: I think what had a little bit of more ground-level architecture.
Ashritha: So, currently, it's going to be a pattern filter kind of thing, because it is pretty sequential, the process that we have.
Ashritha: There are a few open points, like the LMOS, the ML, how you can use it, but that's anyways gonna come into one component. Yeah, exactly. So, like, the architecture-wise, we should be good, to start developing, the next time, startling.
Ashritha: Yeah.
Ashritha: Probably the other thing, too, to be aware of, this is something that's new to us, is that, you know, normally at this point, we are coming up on end-of-semester presentations, and it looks like they're doing something a little different this year. They're doing crits, not end-of-semester presentations, so I'll have to check and find out what the engagement with clients is at all, for these crits or not, so that's kind of new us. I mean, it was always good to have the end of semester, just to get a sense of
Ashritha: What's going on, where they're going, what the plan is for the future, but we're having a meeting with the
Ashritha: all the mentors tomorrow, so Auburn. Yeah, I mean, Sasha sent across an email asking us.
Ashritha: About their availability, and she did mention it very explicitly that
Ashritha: It's not the… it's not necessary to, like, attend your dollars. We don't really, think…
Ashritha: There's no, like, hard rules to work against. And she also mentioned the little kid thing. Yeah, that was beautiful.
Ashritha: Yeah, yeah, as the semester is ending, I guess there's more things all at once, so… Yeah.
Ashritha: Other than that, no one else has something to add?
Ashritha: Because I've, I've mentioned all the points that I had. I'm curious about your last trip to eParts. I had offered to give you a ride, but my car died again, so how did you get there? Yeah, you took an Uber. You took an Uber? Okay, alright.
Ashritha: Yeah, that's a term if they got it fixed, and it'll be okay if they contract again, so… We'll have another meeting, so we can get…
Ashritha: My car has individual coils for each part, and those, those that, and I tried the, you know, third party, those didn't work! You gotta go back and get the expensive OEM. Yeah, unfortunately.
Ashritha: So, you want a reliable transportation, so I apologize, and I do look forward to coming out sometime.
Ashritha: I think, from the last meeting, what Prime discussed for the PIMS architecture, like, now, even after, like, that meeting, I personally don't have any questions. Whatever I had was answering any answers, so…
Ashritha: Yeah, I think the meeting really helped with the architecture part is it, so now we have much more clarity about the options and how all those things are gonna work. Yeah. I think the next question we'll probably have is when we start writing something down, then that's when we'll be happy. Sounds good. Yeah, I mean, summer is probably when we'll be working together as well. Yeah.
Ashritha: That makes sense.
Ashritha: I don't know, did you clue him in with the injury to one of your teammates or not? I don't know what happened? He was, he had a scooter accident, and then, he was pretty bad injured, so that's why he's not with us right now. I mean, he is with us right now, but he's not like… Bad choice. He's not physically in the room, sorry.
Ashritha: He's on Zoom, he's on Zoom. Sorry, engine.
Ashritha: bad choice, of course. I realized it after I spoke.
Ashritha: He's on the call. He's on the call.
arjunnai@andrew.cmu.edu: Bye, guys.
Ashritha: The character.
Ashritha: So what is your, plans for, going back to India and getting your dental work? Yeah.
arjunnai@andrew.cmu.edu: I think I'll be traveling the end of this month, and then I'll be in India for, like, 2-3 weeks.
arjunnai@andrew.cmu.edu: But, I don't think there'll be any disruption in the entire workflow, though. I'll just be taking meetings from India itself.
arjunnai@andrew.cmu.edu: At the same times, so… Should be all good.
Ashritha: I, I, I realize I spoke the wrong word.
Ashritha: Yeah, that's… that's what… that was my agenda.
Ashritha: Anyway, I thought it's important to kind of know what's going on with one of the teammates here. We're glad it's gonna be okay, but sorry to be ahead.
Ashritha: Yeah. Those darn scooters. Yeah. Was it, like,
Ashritha: accident which involved, like, some other person hitting him, or did he just… No, yeah, he got his balance and he…
Ashritha: That's… that's funny.
arjunnai@andrew.cmu.edu: Thank you.
Ashritha: But he did tumble, right? So… Yeah. That would have been so bad boys, yeah.
Ashritha: Anyway, good to hear your voice, everyone.
Ashritha: Yes. Okay. See y'all. Enjoy the nice weather. Yeah, it's warm. Yeah, it's supposed to be cold again, though.
Ashritha: Spring has always been too short. It transitions from winter to summer too quick. I wish we had longer. Definitely. I think this is, like, the longest I've seen, like, the winter part last, at least.
Ashritha: Oh, no, there's been May snow before. May snow? Yeah, there's definitely been snow before we had before. Not for a couple years, though, I feel like.
Ashritha: Just sad that the weather hasn't been conducive. It's just been windy every day. I hate it.
Ashritha: I like the windy weather. Windy's great, but you just can't take a lot of those months. Except for, like, running. Yeah.
Ashritha: Have a good day.
Ashritha: just let us know if you guys need any more data. The only thing that we haven't really sent across is… it's covered in, like, the earlier data set itself sent, but it's just, like, the PIM schema for, like, how the staging is there.
Ashritha: So if you want me to send that across, too, I can.
Ashritha: I think the earlier schema has it mapped, right? It does. This has all the attributes to the categories. So this has all the attributes mapped correctly. So, PIM schema is only useful for you guys if you're actually mapping the data into, like, a final staging schema. But right now, you're just looking at the output kind of thing, so it's not really relevant. We're gonna have…
Ashritha: pretty significant rework of the PIN schema, too. Yeah. But it should be fine for what you're doing, like, for just consolidating some tables, but it's still going to be the same idea of, like, you're just going to be outputting in the staking table, which will allow for the difference. I mean, even in the meeting, you guys told that
Ashritha: the industry standards were still similar enough to what is currently there. I mean, the industry standards are always something we'd recommend you guys to work with. Yes.
Ashritha: Because those are standardized, they won't be affected by how we're feeling on a certain day, and it's always easier to give us some of it.
Ashritha: You do?
Ashritha: How to stop the money?